[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Today I'm
meeting with Joanna Smith
to learn about patterns that I
can use to improve my Android
performance.
So, Joanna, I know you've been
working on this video series,
"Android Development Patterns,"
and you've done a lot of videos
on there.
But tell us what
is it all about,
and where did it come from?
JOANNA SMITH: The original
inspiration actually
was to be a little different.
Most of our outreach
focuses on how an API works.
Whereas we wanted to teach
how to decide on an API
in the first place.
Let's say you're trying
to choose this or that
for a particular situation.
You need to know the
advantages and disadvantages
for the context.
And most people, like
choosing the first answer
they get on Stack
Overflow, will never
understand that context,
which means later,
when they grow their
app and their company,
and it becomes big
and complicated,
they can't make
the best decision.
And I wanted to
empower developers
to be able to make better apps.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
And you do this
through teaching them
patterns rather than a specific
API or something like that.
And my understanding is
for a lot of the patterns,
is that once you've gotten it,
once you've gotten it down,
you can reuse that
again and again.
JOANNA SMITH: Exactly.
That's that context.
Like once you've understood
not just what the answer was,
but how you reached
that answer, you'll
be able to make
decisions in the future.
And I think that's
great for developers.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
Now, you've done a ton of these.
There's a wide variety
of diverse videos.
So shall we take a look at a
quick montage of some of those?
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah,
let's do a review.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-So now you have
three components
that will help you interrupt
your users in the perfect way.
Use the dialog when
the user's response
is critical to your app
flow, because you need to be
disruptive in these moments.
But use a toast to give the user
a tidbit of information that
doesn't change anything.
And for everything in
between, the snack bar
is your new best friend.
So if your user is
on an older SDK,
then you know the
permission was granted
when the app was installed.
However, if your
user's on Marshmallow,
then you can't be so certain.
-Android notifications
have gotten a lot better.
Ever-evolving APIs don't
always make for the easiest
development experience.
And that's why there's
NotificationCompat.
It gives you a single interface
across all API levels,
so you can concentrate
on building
the best notification you can.
In the case of a
fragment pager adapter,
you'll need to
implement GetItem,
which returns a fragment
associated with each position.
[END PLAYBACK]
LAURENCE MORONEY: So you've
done a lot of work here--
lots of videos, lots
of other content.
Where can I find it all?
JOANNA SMITH: Well, on YouTube.
We have a playlist.
Look at that.
We also, though, have
a bunch of blog posts
on Medium under the Google
Developers publication.
Ian and I are both
very active on Twitter.
We have Google+.
There's a collection that
kind of puts all this together
on Google+, so everywhere
on the internet.
LAURENCE MORONEY: We'll
share the links below.
JOANNA SMITH:
Sounds like a plan.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Android
Development Patterns,
ADP-- lots of great
information from Joanna.
All of this available
in the links below.
Please go check them out,
and you go build better apps.